on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from London and
welcome to a special edition of Piers
Morgan uncensored after weeks of heavy
losses and Ukrainian fight back Vladimir
putas made chilling threats of a nuclear
war on the west unsurprisingly as
dominated talks that the UN assembly in
New York this week and prime minister
Liz trust made back in Ukraine one of
the top priorities well at the end of
July I traveled to Ukraine to the
capital city keys and I spoke to two of
the people at the very center of that
fight president zielinski and his wife
the first lady Elena zelensken
foreign
uncensored in Kiev Ukraine and tonight a
world exclusive interview with two of
the most iconic people in the world
right now President Vladimir zielinski
and his wife the first lady of Ukraine
Elena zelenska Mr President nice to meet
you great to see you happy to see you
again thank you so much your English is
better than my Ukrainian yes that's for
sure it was a wide-ranging long
fascinating
heart-rending occasionally laugh out
loud against all the odds interviewed my
grandmother she remembers Churchill he
rallied the whole country and I think
you're doing the same as Churchill I'm
trying
with two compelling people and at the
end of it one thing's for sure Ukraine
right now could not be in better hands
than they are with their president and
their first lady
[Music]
Mr President first lady thank you both
very much indeed for taking this time to
sit down with me I greatly appreciate it
how are you both doing how are you
coping with this
how are you doing how are you doing
your channel well if I may say so to be
honest I have this feeling as if it were
one day that is why when it was the
sixth day the seventh day of War since
that day I really have this feeling that
all of this is one very long day
I don't really see the difference
between five months or six months the
only difference is when we feel that at
the battlefield the situation is
stabilized
or we know that at some points in some
positions we are advancing yes and I
keep thinking about that
but another point is my family my wife
they have found the format how sometimes
we can have this possibility of seeing
each other
thank you for the interview
this interview is one of the good
opportunities for us to see each other
that is very important for us
as you know we are all human beings and
we have to be strong
sometimes we want to have someone close
to be next to us and that is what you
miss in these moments
a
it is
yes I miss my children I miss my wife it
is impossible to get used to it
everything else you can get used to
um
is this like a TV date
yes thank you for this TV date yes yes
because each day each time when we have
this interview we experience Joy because
we have the chance to see each other
throughout past days past months
because during this period volodimer has
been living at his workplace and I'm
with children but we are in another
place we were separated and I can see
him only several times per week in the
office but children do not get to see
him very often of course they they miss
it under such a serious period in their
life of our daughter who graduated from
school she's entering University and
today she's going to take an exam and
she's preparing thoroughly for this even
she really needs her dad to be around to
be able to talk to him and this period
of time and she's entering this adult
life so it's important to make sure that
there's such a smooth transition for her
but unfortunately there's something we
cannot afford and what is supportive
what helps us
you understand that you are not alone
all of the Ukrainian people are in this
situation too many are separated and all
of us are waiting for our Victory and
waiting for normal life to be reunited
again and just to lead normal lives like
Ordinary People live
the only thing that I could add here is
that I absolutely agree with olena I
think that for those people who are in
occupied territories it's much more
difficult and this is something one
cannot get used to actually
so we have to try our best to make sure
we can deoccupy these territories and at
least to save the lives of these people
and to make sure that there is still
hope for them
these kind of situations they can make
or break a marriage is your marriage
stronger do you think because of what
you've gone through in the last few
months what do you think I should I have
to begin to answer
okay okay
I agree with the theory that marriage
gets stronger with challenges and I
think in our case it would be the same
we have become more interested in each
other I think in our case it will be the
same story
we have got something else to say to
each other
that is why I want this challenge to
make us more united
what do you think about it my answer
wouldn't be different
you should have your own opinion about
it
of course I have my own opinions and
when you're next to me your opinion has
priority but I'm interested to hear what
you have to say
yeah well what I can say is that I
didn't have any other experience
actually
because I have only one wife and I'm
happy
yes that's the right answer it is yes
you see I am happy to have this set up I
am happy that in my life I have got one
wife one love and one family yeah
I never got any feeling that there was
anything wrong with us or in our
relationship
and I probably well it is how it is
probably there are different moments in
families and marriages and different
points
or maybe do you feel unhappy with me
sometimes not with you but without you
I'm very unhappy yes yes right
[Music]
that is why I can't notice any big
changes the war is making our
relationship stronger
what is so nice I think is you your
relationship was founded on humor
commonly uh you you wrote comedy scripts
you were writing and Performing and I
was going to ask you later in the
interview if you'd had any chance to
even laugh together and then here you
are laughing together and it's very nice
to see that because that's how you met
and fell in love was making each other
laugh it's true there are no moments of
laughing in our these days or days it's
true and and I and sometimes we I I can
see smile and and also I I have this
minutes for smiling I think it helps
helps very much is it true I've got a
question for you Mr President please is
it true you met at high school you were
a high school sweetheart
is it true you got together with two
friends male friends and all of you
propose marriage to your wife and to two
other women at the same time it is true
it was yes I don't remember exactly why
we did such ways if you remember could
you please tell a story yes they had
very many very many performances then
and we were always on the road sometimes
it was with them and their girlfriends
were also with them and when we saw that
we had more flexible schedule for the
upcoming months then the guys decided to
put it to good use because we plan to
get married anyway I remember you three
guys saying let's do it and everything
will be okay and we agreed
let's let's do the right thing and we
agreed somehow you know we agreed yes
I remember we were having a wedding
ceremony every week yes
yes ours is on the 6th of September and
then another couple on the 13th of
September so each Saturday we would have
another function to celebrate it yes
that shows that at the time I didn't
have many friends but if I had 10 or 20
friends we would have had weddings all
over the years
it's a lovely story and you've all got
married within the same two-week period
right
yes all three marriages amazing uh Mr
President
well the most important thing is not to
have divorces every week that we are
managing we are managing yes we are
managing is not the right word
we are in love with each other okay okay
Mr President
started that all
night back in February you appeared very
soon afterwards and made a video address
which you put out on social media I
remember watching it in real time and
being removed by it and it was really
your decision to stay here in Ukraine
and to encourage the people of Ukraine
to fight for their country some leaders
might have left what made you stay
foreign
because the president is a leader of its
people
the people voted for me and the
strengths of our state
this is something that I have already
mentioned the strengths of our state
this is consolidation
this is unity of our people all of us
together the government the people the
servicemen people just want it started
they would go to the streets they would
stop tanks other military vehicles so
the government had to stay in the center
of the decision-making processes
it was very important to make sure that
there is no informational chaos because
we cannot say that this intimidation
works because otherwise they would say
that their informational propaganda
actually won that the government would
leave this is what they wanted
is chaos because chaos is the weakness
of the state
this is the weakness of Institutions so
one can occupy some territory very
quickly
frankly yes
unfortunately in some places some
settlements or towns of Ukraine this is
what happened
with some police officers some local
authorities yes they would they would
actually run away and it was possible
for the troops to address sooner but
actually there was a lot of resistance
and it was next to impossible to occupy
because of the resistance coming from
people
this is why we really tried really hard
to make sure that other territories
remain integral that was the only way
for me to act
and I understood the consequences and I
think that these consequences they were
so much more important than what happens
to me the next day
first lady that night you had to wake
your children and tell them this Ward
started your children at 18 and nine
years old that must have been a very
difficult thing to do and then you had
to leave your husband as you went to
lead the country and you had to leave
him perhaps
fearing I don't know you tell me that
you may never see him again
yes it was difficult it I was a little
bit worried actually when I had to wake
up the children to let them know that
the war had begun and that we had to
park some stuff but luckily I didn't
have to do that because when I entered
the room of my daughter and she was
already awake and she understood
everything because you know social media
everything works so fast these days I
didn't see in her eyes any panic
she just asked me
what do we have to do now and that was
exactly the same question which I
addressed to my husband
and what he told me was wait wait and I
will tell you
had some thoughts
would it be possible for me to see him
again how long is going to last what
happens next the fear was there but I
try not to show it to the children that
I was confused that I was scared and I
was not really scared but it was
important for me to be in a cheerful
mood to keep talking to them to smile to
them that is what I had to do and after
this very long day believe me my cheeks
hurt because I had to smile so much and
to be cheerful
and there's volodimer just said as for
any Ukrainian the 24th of February keeps
repeating every day
you know this is the 24th of February is
a permanent condition in which we are
living right now as the circumstances
are changing but we're just waiting for
one thing when all of that is going to
be
all rolled back and we will be back to
our normal lives that is why I don't I
wouldn't really want anyone in the whole
world to endure this horrific days that
we had to go through at the end of
February yes but we hope for better
absolutely absolutely we are sure about
our future we believe in peace we
believe in our Victory
and I absolutely agree well this is the
way it is we are living in these times
social media they work faster they
explain things faster than parents do
sometimes and we can say that it's not
only about our children we have children
of War they hear a lot about what's
happening they understand that these war
made them more grown up and there are
very many important things which have to
be explained by parents
your son I believe he now wants to be a
soldier yes how do you feel about that
yeah
I'm proud of that
I am proud of our army and as a father I
would be proud if my son became a
soldier I can provide support for him
I know he is wearing military style
clothing he's got quite a lot of weapons
not the kind of weapons we've got from
our partners
I mean he's ready to protect his mother
and our family it must be strange for
your children because you've become this
this International hero to many people
uh incredibly famous the whole world
knows of you and is in is inspired by
you and yet to your children you're just
your dad and you they see you on
television I presume and it still is
their father not this Global guy hold by
still father yeah understood
for them but have you seen them at all
at some point there was the movement of
my family to different places it was
important in terms of security of my
family
it was not possible for us to
communicate or to use any means of
communication for some longer periods of
time
at some point it was possible for us to
have an online date and I saw my
children
how was that
nice great yeah I'm proud of them and
they are proud of me and it is such a
delight because this is what it gets you
through this is what I can hear first
lady
the world sees your husband as a hero is
he your hero
yeah maybe you want to answer without me
yes I think it would be better I think
that I have already answered similar
questions a couple of times already and
if each time I have to answer this
question because of Victory is getting
closer and closer you know I cannot make
up any other answer
there's only one truth
I have always known that he's the most
trustworthy person ever and under this
condition this is something the world
learned
and the same is true about our children
he has always been a champion for them
the best dad the best person in our
family and right now they're not really
surprised they take it as a test they
have this confidence and they support
I'm one of the best ones in our family
yes you're the one of the
of
the
family
but there's not many
the president having having spent time
with have you spent time with the first
lady at the summit all day are you
familiar with the phrase punching above
your weight you familiar with that
phrase
it means you're doing you're very lucky
you're doing very well yeah yeah I think
so
I'm very lucky with my wife
I got really lucky to have her as a wife
with my family with my children
I think that I'm a happy person I am
absolutely a happy person
view of Vladimir Putin the man who is
leading this war he is Enemy Number One
in this war it seems to me the scariest
thing about it is that he is in fact
sane and he understands what he's doing
it is difficult to put it into words
it's not possible to understand how one
crooked idea can throw the whole of
mankind into the Medieval ages
I really don't have words
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
s you're the number one target for them
and your family is the number two target
that must be a constant pressure for all
of you
but it's not really about you thinking
about your family yes in this case the
family is at the center of attention and
yes this is true
these targets still remain for some
people from the Russian Federation
as far as I am concerned I think it is a
given I think that it is a part of this
situation we are in and we are in a
state of War I think that's any person
can become a Target
there is an example there is a good
example of the number of
artillery missiles and some other
strikes which took place
innocent people suffer civilians suffer
Are Soldiers and me if I can really put
it this way
we are at War we were at War yes we
understand that these things could
happen the result could be a bad one
some people lose their lives
what about suffering of civilians
their families
common people
and the only thing they did was being a
Ukrainian
because this is what it is for Ukrainian
soldiers and politicians
that is why I think this is something
which is unsettling
and first lady for you as a mother
to know that the Russians
are targeting not just your husband as
president but you and your potentially
your children your family
for any mother that that must be a
terrifying thought
yeah
I tried never to think about this
numbers of targets because when you
think in terms of Target number one
target number two
if you think too much into it then you
can become really paranoid and yes I
understand I'm a mother like many other
mothers in Ukraine that is why all
ukrainians are Targets number two and of
course it's all unpleasant feeling I
don't want to think that they want to do
this to our family I'm trying to push
this kind of thoughts away I can see
that you can see what they did to
civilians and what they're doing now in
any part of our country I don't
understand what they've got in mind and
possibly we are in danger I don't want
to allow this kind of thought to go deep
into my mind because I could feel scared
and this is not what we need right now
first lady I remember your husband going
to Butcher and the emotion and fury on
his face I know you felt the same about
this and you've talked about how the
civilization and then there's what's
going on here and the Russians are
behaving in a way that you just never
imagined possible a total lack of
humanity
tell me about that
no
no
any civilized person during this war
would have terrible feelings
fear and hate towards the enemy and we
tried to explain it to come on
Englishmen when they take their child to
bed try to imagine what is going to
happen at night if they had the sirens
and explosions next to where they live
what would they grab from their
children's bedroom and where would they
run to if they recognized there's
already a large queue of cars trying to
leave the city are they going to take
their pets with them and imagine if you
stayed there and you earned the
occupation
imagine the road you usually take your
child to school with tanks on it
the grave of your close relative in your
back Garden because you can't have a
normal funeral to remember them
and imagine you have to search for water
and you only source is a dirty puddle
like it was in mariopul
the medical service is not available
just imagine you are in your home and in
two hours time you are forced to deal
with these kinds of problems just to
survive you don't understand why this is
happening
what is your view of Vladimir Putin the
man who is leading this war
s
it's not possible to understand how one
crooked idea can throw the whole of
mankind into the Medieval ages
I really don't have words and I really
don't want to say anything aloud because
Normal words don't exist to describe
this
president he is your enemy in this war
he's the leader of Russia they've been
doing despicable things to your people
bombing maternity hospitals committing
war crimes no question torturing people
murdering them what is your view your
opinion of Vladimir Putin
okay
well it's clear and as you have
mentioned he is Enemy Number One in this
war
it seems to me the scariest thing about
it is that he is in fact sane and he
understands what he's doing I'd say
that's the scariest conclusion I can
make that he understands what he's doing
he knows how many people he kills
he knows how many people were raped and
by who
and the number of children killed or
deported
therefore
I only understand one thing
the world allowed the situation to
develop
it allowed such a person to emerge
with that ideology and attitude towards
people
the world should understand that this
result this mistake to allow this
situation is the responsibility of the
whole world to give the possibility for
this to happen it is not about democracy
I wouldn't want to mix these things
because some leaders say that what did
we have to do it it is not really about
democracy do you believe do you believe
you can win this war
that yes no question yeah yeah
I don't only believe it I know it will
happen
we will win
we already showed the whole world that
he can kill us
but to conquer our people is impossible
millions of soldiers have died but he
cannot occupy the people how important
how important
he can occupy these towns and Villages
but all of them would be destroyed
because without ruining them they will
not be able to take those places
how important has it been to get support
from so much of the world for Ukraine
this is the nature this is the goal
number two like you said there is the
aim number one number two
but there are also the goals of Ukraine
our goals Is Our Land
that's number one
both number one and number two This Is
Our Land and our people
how we can get it we need some help
and nowadays it's very important
but number two is of course the union of
our country
trends of the country and it leads to
the help from like an ambulance they
help from the world nine one one from
the whole world
and exactly right now we need this
powerful help do you believe he would
ever use a nuclear weapon Putin yeah I
don't know
I don't know I don't know what his aims
are I don't know what the Civilized
World allows him to do because if it
shows its weakness he will use
everything
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
the other argument that you will hear
and I'm sure you've heard it is that
Putin has all these nuclear weapons no
one should do anything to trigger world
war three what do you say yeah
I think that if he decides to use it
then there will be no reason for that
explicit reason is only about his
decision their ambitious plans just
listen to me in any other case What If
tomorrow he says you know what Germany I
think that half of there was this
division in the country after the second
world war and I think that that part of
Germany belongs to us
I think that we should have some
influence upon the territory and our
troops should be there in the other case
nuclear weapons
raise our hands do this I don't believe
this this is the choice Europe and the
USA
I think we should not really believe in
that do you believe he would ever use a
nuclear weapon Putin yeah I don't know
I don't know I don't know what his aims
are I don't know what the Civilized
World allows him to do because if it
shows its weakness he will use
everything
you mentioned Germany Mr President one
of the more sickening things that Putin
has said is that he's liberating
Ukrainian people from Nazis my
implication you you're a Jewish man you
had relatives who were murdered by the
Nazis that must have been for you a
particularly egregious insult
it's not that it is unpleasant to hear
it you know this is I don't pay
attention to that these are empty words
if something is very populous for their
people I pay no attention to this
if you want to draw attention to these
questions
then the first you need to think about
their first actions and the results of
what they're doing they are Nazis and
take a look at biography and the people
who are close to Putin his family what
happened to them during the times when
the Nazis were out there during the
second World War what was happening who
did he get to lose and for him to take a
look at my family what is their blood
where are they now
and why I don't truly have a big family
I mean people who are still here by the
way tortured by Nazis what happened to
his family were they under occupation
they were not
so what was happening so I would
probably pay attention to that it's not
really about him I think that political
leaders of the Russian Federation I will
pay more attention to their families is
of the utmost importance President Biden
said that Putin should be removed from
office
do you agree
that
I think that any war ends with when we
talk about diplomatic Solutions and the
impression that I have is that the
result of this diplomacy is the
conversations between the Ukrainian part
with the presence of our partners and
the Russian Federation
I think that this is the only model
to talk with with someone else not the
Contemporary leader of the Russian
Federation is there more America could
be doing right now that's so powerful
obviously as a country yeah president as
the president of a country that is in a
war
I can tell you that the housing would
not be sufficient until the war is over
and until we win
so you understand Lewis president a few
times I've spoken with President Biden
and I told him about our people and
about our country I said forgive me if
I'm quite firm in my position maybe some
things are not very diplomatic but he
gave me quite a dignified response that
he understands and he would do the same
in my place he would do the same thing
there are people in America uh some on
the Republican side in particular who
think that America shouldn't be spending
all this money on a wall here which has
nothing to do with them they think there
are more important things in America
like inflation and so on that they
should be working on what is your
message to those Americans who do not
think America should be as heavily
involved
we are fighting for absolutely communal
values that our universally understood
some time ago I responded that war
doesn't have a distance and the war in
Ukraine is still the war against those
values that are professed in the United
States and in Europe this time the
distance doesn't exist today
Russian Rockets can fly over a few
thousand kilometers and tomorrow they
will have rockets that can cover tens of
thousands of kilometers what difference
does it make they kill civilians who do
not agree with the politics of the
president of Russia so this war here and
now in Ukraine and forgive me I'm saying
it's so cynically it's for the safety of
Europe as long as we are resisting the
Integrity of the United States will
continue
therefore we are giving our lives for
your values and The Joint security of
the world
therefore the inflation is nothing
ask those people who lost their children
their peace they're property at the
beginning of the full-scale Russian
invasion who is thinking about masks who
is thinking about inflation these things
are secondary the most important thing
is to survive and preserve your life
family and your country therefore at the
moment we are doing this job but the
West has to help us
first lady is it true that he didn't
tell you that he was going to run for
president
well he forgot
if God you forgot to tell your wife
you're running for president
you found that on TV
Mr President really you you announced
before you told your wife
I was not laughing so much so loud
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I want to take you back to a few years
ago when you were a comedy performer in
a hugely popular TV show in which you
played an anti-establishment figure
who runs for president and becomes
president
and then you actually run for president
in real life and you become president
it's a bit crazy when you
say it like that the question is that
for many people it was surreal that you
were playing a role in a comedy show as
someone who becomes president and then
you become the real president
well it is a reality this is the reality
which we're all living now to be honest
I am proud of the fact that this is how
it happened I'm proud of being the
president of Ukraine that people voted
for me it is a reality and about this
surreal thing I think it's more about
what is actually happening with our
neighbors
for very many years we they lived
alongside and then they decided to
attack us and to kill us
I think it is way more surreal than this
first lady is it true that he didn't
tell you that he was going to run for
president
say true
[Music]
[Applause]
forgot to tell your wife you're running
for president
he understood that probably I wouldn't
have been fond of this idea and that it
will take a couple of hours of very
difficult negotiations with me that is
why probably each day he was thinking
that this is the day that this is the
moment I should tell her you know but he
kept postponing it then it was on TV I
saw his new year's address it was New
Year's night and found out he was
actually running yesterday wait a minute
you found that on TV
really you announced it on television
before you told your wife
[Music]
I was not laughing so much so loud
yes he was sitting next to me
there was a long time
10 minutes but that wasn't it okay say
everything okay this question was up in
the air there were some discussions but
it didn't really want to do to keep
asking him you are going to tell them is
it happening is it not somehow I believe
that at that point he will tell me but I
didn't really think that that would be
the moment you have to explain yourself
yes I mean I've heard of not telling
your wife this but not telling you
you're going to be president it's like
crazy
what were you thinking
no no no
at least you see was a difficult
decision for our family
I knew that it would hit that yeah
it would be a tough call it's not a joke
are serious matters
it's true that we didn't talk about it
for a long period of time
because my family was not prepared to
let me go
you are right my first public statement
that was before the day of New Year
I mentioned that I am intending to run
to the office
it is true that was the moment when well
then I heard about that okay
and she told me that she didn't want
that but the decision
this is your opportunity to apologize to
your wife okay
[Laughter]
well that is my that you know
why not
later do it later when you apologize
again
you were written off at the start of
this war by the New York Times called
you an inept leader unsuitable for war
another headline this comedian turned
president is in seriously over his head
they couldn't have been more wrong
you've turned out to be the right man at
the right time for your country you've
been an incredibly inspiring leader in
this war
what do you say to those who doubted you
yeah
what can I say I'm happy that right now
they can see how wrong they were and
that they admit it personally do you
feel that Ukraine is fortunate to have
your husband leading the country at this
time
well I think
country I cannot really say but this is
how I feel it and yes this is what I can
say on behalf of everyone that we
believe in him and this is the way
people feel I'm not only his wife I also
a citizen of this country and I like
this president
laughs
at this Summit which was magnificent
your first lady and first gentleman
Summit which I was proud to help
moderate for you
um there was a moment when I revealed
that my football team Arsenal have
signed a Ukrainian player
Alexander zinchenko I'm very excited
about this it's just happened and I
asked the audience are there any Arsenal
fans in the room and you put your hand
up you're an [ __ ]
yes I think that XI chenco is the person
who is loved by everyone in Ukraine he
is one of the most recent Heroes of the
nation and ukrainians they always
violently support football players and
xinjin was such a nice guy and even
girls like him so much this is why I'm
hopeful when xinjinco starts playing our
people will become fans of this football
team
Mr President are you are you an Arsenal
supporter yeah maybe there's some other
footballers that you like let me explain
I know some of them personally let me
explain why you should be because
Arsenal is named after a weapons Factory
which used to make weapons for the
British Army and the Royal Navy
and our motto the motto of the club is
in Latin Victoria
Concordia crescott which stands for
victory through Harmony
it's appropriate yeah and yeah
honestly we are all fans of zinchenko as
Elena has mentioned
personally I know very many great
Ukrainian football players so to be
honest they are doing a great thing they
are working really hard they're
well-known people and they're helping us
a lot
chefchenko is a great person I cannot
say that I love zinc or for chefchenko
because and chefchenko will stop talking
to me and then I can do the opposite
thing you know there are so many of them
believe me there are some legendary
figures they took arms and they are on
the front line and we know some football
players from other teams from Dynamo so
I mean that I'm a fan of football like
any man in Ukraine we've now established
thanks to the first lady you're all
Arsenal supporters and I actually have a
gift for you which I will give you after
the interview of Arsenal shirts for the
president for the first lady and for
both of your children because we need
your support as we'll give you our
support
um thank you both very much indeed for
all the time that you've given me today
I think I speak on everyone's behalf in
the United Kingdom when I salute you for
the courage that you've shown the
inspiration you've shown the people here
we're all behind you
we need you to win this war we
understand the world needs you to win
this war
keep fighting and I think the words I
need to use are Slava Ukrainian glory to
the heroes thank you very much thank you
[Music]
thank you
I'm Tony Dunn and this is talk TV the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited
has to be interviewing president Trump
in the Oval Office in the White House
particularly little red button he had on
his desk I have no idea what he did his
interview went up I wanted more rumors
is going to launch a nuclear strike on
North Korea or open up a sharp pit that
I've then fall into turn out he pressed
it right at the end of the interview and
then walked to Butler with a train
carrying a dark with him he was a diet
Cooper
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Emily Rose Adams the
chancellor has rejected accusations that
his new economic plan is a gamble after
he unveiled 45 billion pounds worth of
tax cuts despite surging inflation and a
pound that's losing value quasi
quatang's budget marks the biggest tax
cutting event since 1972 and a
significant change in Economic Policy
the overhaul includes scrapping the top
rate of income tax for the highest
earners bringing forward a cut in the
basic rate and slashing stamp Duty the
cap on Bankers bonuses has also been
scrapped well it's fair to say the
shake-up hasn't gone down well with
Global Investors Sterling bonds and
share values have fallen sharply the
pound drops more than three percent
against the dollar today to 1.9 the
lowest since the 1980s that's all for
now we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]